okay hey listen to this I used to do
this segment like once a week or once
every two weeks where I would present to
you a book that I was reading or that I
had finished reading and I would give
book recommendations and the segment's
never did super well maybe it's because
there aren't that many people in our
audience that are regularly reading
books that may be the case but when I
stopped doing it I got a lot of very
strong emails saying that people really
liked that segment and that I should
keep doing it so I want to just try to
bring it back I'm not going to be doing
it every week but I've got a stack of my
books here that I've recently read in am
reading I'll tell you what they are
maybe there's something in it that you
want to read if you like this let me
know if you don't like it if it gets 500
views on YouTube or something like that
maybe it's a sign that the audience
isn't super into it but let's give it a
shot because I've got a bunch of stuff
I've been wanting to tell you about
nonfiction to start with I've been
reading this really great book we wish
to inform you that tomorrow we will be
killed with our families it's by Philip
Gurevich it is a 20 years old at this
point it's about the Rwandan genocide in
which a huge portion of the Tutsi
population of Rwanda was exterminated
and I think that that's the right word
to use by the Hutu I did not ever read
anything in depth about it really really
good book another non-fiction book I
recently read by Jon Ronson who's been a
guest on this program who wrote the
psychopathy test or the sociopath test
cycle psychopathy I think the book is so
you've been publicly shamed it's very
interesting in that it looks at public
social media shaming and when and where
people are and aren't sort of redeemable
which i think is a big problem in social
media culture he tells stories including
those of people we've interviewed on the
show like jonah lehrer who was caught in
a plagiarism and sort of fabrication
scandal really good book quick read it's
300 pages I think I read it in a weekend
because it's such a quick read I think
this one I've mentioned before escaped
from camp 14 by Blaine harden this is
the story of a North Korean
born in a North Korean prison camp who
escaped told his story turned out that
the story as initially told was not
completely accurate and that is
addressed in the book fascinating book
including about the conditions in these
North Korean labor camps highly
recommended also a quick read something
a little different a little more
academic combining two topics that are
interesting to me coffee and Judaism
this book is called
a rich brew how cafes created modern
Jewish culture and it's a really
interesting sort of tour of cafes dating
back to the 19th century starting in
Odessa in Poland in New York City etc my
home city of Buenos Aires is mentioned
here really really interesting book it
is certainly dense and academic it's by
su char-char Pinsker rather recommend it
not a quick read I will be very clear
about and then lastly on the nonfiction
side the righteous mind by Jonathan Hite
Jonathan hight was on the show a couple
of months ago this is not his newest
book this one is from let me take a look
here 2012 but it is a very interesting
analysis of how he Jonathan Hite sees
not so-called tribalism but what's
called group ashiness as a mechanism
through which we can understand how
modern Paul it's a political
partisanship has developed a really
really good book the righteous mind by
Jonathan hight okay those are a few
non-fiction recommendations are you
seeing anything here Pat that's remotely
interesting to you or is this is this
not a good list for you no I think it's
a great list the one about the Rwanda
genocide I'd like to read I think
because I'm not too studied up on that
am I allowed to give a recommendation of
my own to or is that not allowed we're
gonna have to bleep that out you can do
it as long as it's not a recommendation
that I never do this again
okay how about how we got to now the six
inventions that made the modern world
that's the book that I'm wrapping up
right now it's actually due back at the
library in two days so I got to be quick
with it it's about the importance of
inventing refrigeration glass
bulb really interesting stuff that's the
recommendation I would give to you today
yep
that book is actually on my list of
things I want to read I think Bill Gates
may have recommended that although he
might have recommended how the world
became modern which is slightly that's a
different book but yes that is high I
agree with that recommendation from Pat
okay to fiction recommendations number
one
Elliot pepper sent an early copy his new
book breach doesn't even come out until
May 14th he sent me an advanced copy
which I finished last week and it's
excellent I called this a techno
thriller and he may disagree with that
I hate massage on aura in books but this
is really good and I would encourage you
to preorder it or potentially get it on
May 14th the idea is it's a world where
there is a company that is a
transnational company that controls
what's called the feed the feed manages
everything from social networks to
transactions - it's sort of like a
souped-up Internet all-seeing Google
type of entity and it's a world the
series is called analog all based around
that sort of circumstance and then that
got me interested in this other book
which I'm now reading info Mach recei
info Mach recei is by Malka older and
info Mach recei is a very interesting
concept where instead of having national
elections the way we do now where the
united states elects a president and
then china elects a president maybe a
president for life the entire world has
been divided into what are called
sentinels each of which have I now
forget if it's ten thousand or a hundred
thousand people so in the u.s. we have
congressional districts with seven
hundred thousand seven hundred something
thousand people each the idea is the
entire planet is divided up into these
ten or hundred thousand person sentinels
each of which gets to elect
representative governments some of the
governments are corporations some of the
government's are algorithms and don't
even have like a specific person
associated very interesting and highly
recommend that you
check it out okay let me know do you
care about these recommendations or is
this boring stuff